today we're talking about fluids my
favorite my area of expertise we're
gonna do an experiment and then we're
gonna understand
why
what we saw happened using maths we're
gonna do some magic but explained
through maths hey duck wow here i have a
sieve which has some holes in so when i
pour
the water goes through the sieve right
so i'm not cheating fill up my pint
glass
put the sieve on top and then i'm going
to get this plate
and position it on here and i'm going to
turn it over this something's going to
leak but hopefully not too much
and now the magic part is i'm going to
actually lift up this and remove the
plate and the water will not fall out
there we go
that was off the plate that doesn't
count somehow the water is completely
remaining
inside the glass we've got the heavier
fluid on top the more dense water with
air underneath
and now if i want to make it fall
through again show you i'm not cheating
if i move this a little bit
it falls out
so what was happening there was the
surface tension of the water was holding
the water in the glass and stopping it
from falling out let's try the colander
there's much bigger holes yeah if you
compare the two there's definitely much
bigger holes in the bottom
so you can see i'm not cheating i need
to put this on top
and then i turn it over and now if i can
grab the handle of this slowly and
carefully
this one's harder
oh that was off the plate there we go
we've got the water inside the glass
being held inside the glass despite
there being holes in the bottom of the
colander
and yet the water doesn't pass through
it remains in this precarious position
of the heavier fluid the water above the
lighter fluid here
of the air and just like before if i
were to slightly move this
then it all leaks out
amazing amazing i agree so the last
thing i've got is this sort of gauze
kind of thing and again we can like
pour the water through so these holes
are quite big right now let's try this
you can get this one to work
my stopper on top and my plate there's
gonna be quite a lot of leakage i think
here
okay
so i can't do that i've kind of got it
ah
no
it's not gonna work i've tried this a
few times this one doesn't work
trying to build the suspense so
the the problem here
is the holes are too big basically is
what's happening so so we started with
our very fine
mesh on the sieve so the holes there are
tiny tiny little holes so we have the
bigger holes for the colander here
and then
seems like well let's keep going we went
bigger to the gauze but this time the
holes were too big
the surface tension wasn't able to
support
the heavier fluid being on top and the
water fell through that to me sounds
like we need to investigate this
mathematically it's actually like
looking through the window yeah i told
you he comes to say hello so
we what we had in our experiment was
actually a two layer fluid system this
is my interface and this is important
water on top and then we had air below
so two different fluids and we're going
to call the density at the top row t so
we use row for density and t means top
and the bottom row b so obviously in our
experiment we had row t water is more
dense heavier than air along the
interface we've also got surface tension
t and surface tension the reason i've
drawn it like this is it acts
tangentially along the tangent of our
shape of our surface and we want to
figure out now can we derive a
mathematical expression explaining the
forces and what's going on either side
of this interface and can we figure out
why we're okay for small holes but past
a certain critical hole size
it actually fell through because we're
talking about fluids we've got nowhere
stokes equations i love navier stokes
but what's really key here is to think
about this interface which is why i was
keen to label this because it's the
conditions on the interface that really
determine what's happening here so what
we've got is a boundary condition which
we call the dynamic bc for boundary
condition and now this tells us that on
the interface we must have a force
balance they just must always balance or
they must balance for the water to stay
they actually must balance anyway
because and this comes from newton's
second law
because newton's second law says f
equals ma the net force is mass times
acceleration but our interface it's like
infinitely thin like i can draw this but
does it have a mass
it doesn't have a mass you can make the
mass of it is basically zero so if this
side of newton's second law is zero the
force the net force has to be zero so in
order to not contradict
newton's second law of motion this must
be true as i said dynamic boundary
condition the forces must balance and
we've got tension we've got this
difference in density and of course
we've got gravity pointing us down
that's going to be the other key force
and then we have a second boundary
condition which is called the kinematic
boundary condition and this tells you
that fluid particles on the interface
must remain there so this is saying if i
imagine there's sort of being particles
of fluid all bunched up along here as
time progresses this particle can't jump
out and have another one replace it
because the interface is
the boundary the particles on the top
and then if one of them moves if that
will move down your interface would move
down that's kind of what the kinematic
boundary condition is saying so there's
some kind of physical intuition
hopefully it makes some kind of sense
we're saying that if you are on the
interface then you have to stay there
and now given these two important
conditions
along the interface and given navier
stokes we can actually write down our
equation that's going to control the
shape of the interface because that's
going to be key in determining when the
water can and can't fall through i guess
that's the lady duck isn't that i think
yeah because the other ones are like
green aren't they the mallard ducks
there's the man i i told you it was a
pair the equation that we end up with
omega squared is equal to the density
difference between our fluids times
gravity so that's like our gravitational
force plus surface tension multiplied by
2 pi divided by the wavelength squared
all multiplied by 2 pi over the
wavelength and then the whole thing
divided by the sum of the densities now
the densities are given by our setup t
is surface tension and g is
gravitational acceleration so the other
things that we've introduced here are
omega
and lambda
so omega this is
the frequency of our waves
so this is along our interface where we
have this wave-like shape this is us
saying if i fix a position
then i let time progress i'm looking at
my interface the waves will kind of move
along in time so you can imagine let's
take a a fairly gentle still day at the
ocean
so there are waves along the surface of
the ocean and if you look at a certain
patch there would be a frequency number
of waves per second
so this is the frequency of those waves
and here it's the frequency the waves
along the interface the shape of the
wave is represented by lambda which is
the wavelength so that horizontal
distance there is equal to lambda lambda
is the wavelength
the frequency in time
is omega and the reason we're talking or
interested in waves
is
if this is going to exist
if this actual situation with water on
the top an air on the bottom this is
going to be possible
and like sit there
stable to be stable sit there nice and
happy
you need waves along the interface it's
not going to be flat like these
interfaces aren't perfectly flat there's
going to be some even if you have to
zoom in to almost microscopic level
there's some
wiggliness
to that interface and we want to model
this as though it's a wave so like um
adding together causes and signs and
things why does it have to be a wave why
can't just be some amorphous random so
it possibly could but something that
we can show mathematically which i'm not
going to go into but you can actually
use fourier series which is you add
together more and more signs and causes
and you can create any shape that you
want so you can literally have something
that's really spiky or like a square you
just add together causes and signs in
the right way through this theory of
four asus so you can always use cosine
which we think of as waves so when i say
waves it's not perfectly like this
but we're talking about cars and sign
oscillations
sort of like the trigonometric graphs
this tells us that if waves are to exist
then this formula is true and that would
be stable that would mean that this
thing sort of holds
if waves can't exist
then
as in the water falls through
then we can't have waves right something
else is happening it would be you could
think of it as either some like random
motion some chaos some
growth of the wave whatever's happening
it's not nice and gentle and oscillating
the system collapsed yes the system
collapsed the system breaks exactly and
what we can do now from this equation in
fact is think about when that can happen
this is a square number so we want to
square root to find the frequency of our
waves number of waves per second if this
thing is negative then i get a frequency
that's an imaginary number and that's a
clue that the system is breaking or
collapsing and everything like that's
just that means the water's falling
through so four waves which corresponds
to stable what we need is this thing to
all be positive right hand side must be
positive because if it is i square root
i get the frequency waves can exist yeah
they've just settled on my little
fatty i like it
right so when is this positive
case one so everything here is pretty
positive actually when you look so we've
got
g is positive t is positive we've got
lambda is a wavelength it's a
measurement so it's positive pi is
positive density is positive
everything's positive apart from this
minus sign so in case one we can
consider the case
where
the bottom density is bigger than the
top density so this would actually mean
i had water on the bottom air on the top
so this is either an actual normal way
of holding a glass of water so you're
going to drink it or this is like the
air in the ocean
this is nice and stable
and because the heavier fluid is on the
bottom
this is always positive which is why we
always get waves so that's why you sort
of you know the ocean is in general nice
and well behaved and why you can have a
glass of water and it's never going to
jump out or anything crazy is going to
happen it just sits there happily
because the heavier fluid is on the
bottom
so it's always good to do a sanity check
with these things because we know we
know the physics we have the intuition
as people going about our lives you want
to check the maths actually fits with
our daily experiences i wonder what
brought them here because there's no
like pond
case two is when we have the one we
really care about here is where the
heavier fluid is on the top so now i
look at my formula here for the
frequency
so this
row t is bigger than this
so this thing is now negative
here so you've got something negative
plus something positive and we only care
about the sign of this so we don't care
about the bottom that's always positive
this is always positive so it's just
this square bracket so if the right hand
side of our equation here if that's
going to be negative right hand side is
negative then that can only happen when
the square bracket is negative rho b
minus rho t times gravity plus tension 2
pi over lambda all squared so when
that's negative since rho t is bigger
than rho b we're going to take this
across the inequality so we can say that
t 2 pi over lambda squared is less than
g and now it's rho t minus rho b this is
now a positive number top density is
bigger than the bottom top is water so
this is now a positive number this
positive number and then what we want to
do here actually is t is fixed it's the
surface tension so for a certain set of
fluids that has a value obviously two
and pi are fixed gravity's fixed the
densities are fixed by the fluids so
what we can control
here is the wavelength possibly so we
want to rearrange this expression for
the wavelength
so we do that we're going to multiply up
divide through square root for waves to
happen and everything to be okay we need
lambda the wavelength less than 2 pi
times the square root of t divided by g
times the density difference where
importantly in this case the fluid on
top is bigger than on the bottom so
we're square rooting a positive number
which makes sense so this is it this is
our condition
if this holds
if we have
a short wavelength so their shape is
quite condensed then
this will actually hold we get waves the
water will stay in the glass and will
not fall out as we saw in the experiment
so now we just want to plug in the
numbers to figure out why did it work
for some of our holes or not for the
others so t the surface tension between
air and water is 0.07
newtons per meter gravity is 9.81
newtons per kilogram density of the top
fluid is water is about a thousand
kilograms per meter cubed for it being
fresh water and on the bottom is 1.2
kilograms per meter cubed so there are
numbers we plug them in and we get that
our wavelength has to be less than
1.7
centimeters
so when we have our glass upside down
with the water and then air below it
surface tension is able to hold it in
place and allow the interface to exist
with waves provided the wavelength is
less than 1.7 centimeters and the way we
control that
is by making our holes
less than 1.7 centimeters so tom the
holes themselves are kind of physically
constraining the wavelength exactly
that's exactly the way to think about it
so when i had the whole glass it's like
10 centimeters across so it's possible
there for a 10 centimeter wave to form
we're not going to see it but it's
possible but when we have the holes they
actually restrict because as the water
can't flow through the hole with a large
wavelength which it needs to that's why
for the sieve they were really small
like a millimeter or two millimeters so
definitely less than this value then
when we went to the colander with the
medium size they're about pushing half a
centimeter maybe 0.3.4 so they're a bit
bigger and then for the last one the the
gauze so they're almost a centimeter
which still seems to be less than this
but this is just giving us an upper
bound so this is this is an
approximation right we've for instance
very at the very beginning we assumed
that the fluid was two-dimensional
here so i've just said it's a 2d slice
through the fluid so that's a huge
simplification and there's other
simplifications we've made because we
know we can't solve full narrative
stokes so we simplify everything so that
because of the approximations this won't
be perfect
but
it sort of gives us an idea that there's
there is a critical hole size and if we
go too big with our holes we've got no
chance
and so it sort of gives us a nice bit of
maths to explain this apparent magic of
the of the floating water
i figured it out i figured out why
they're coming to your office all the
time what is it because of that
the rubber turkey
it's funny